-It is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Now, this is --
This is "WeTweet."
-"WeTweet."
-This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
Okay?
So I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you like
each one or not, okay?
So, everyone has
your voting clickers
at your seats, if you see them.
If you see these things -- yeah.
-Yep.
-Don't take them home.
Leave them here.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, so far --
Yes, very well-organized.
Everyone found them.
Most -- Majority of the --
Thank God
there wasn't a fire here...
[ Laughter ]
...or this would be a nightmare.
-Oh, my -- people
are getting on their knees.
-Just pretend you found
the clickers, gosh.
All right, good,
there you go, yeah.
-There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We had them hidden. We thought
that'd be fun if we...
-Yeah.
We threw some loose change...
-All right, so, you can vote
for all of these if you want,
or you can vote
for none of them.
It's up to you.
Whatever you want,
whatever you're feeling.
You could vote for two of them,
three of them.
If you like 'em,
press thumbs up.
Higgins, you have a clicker,
as well?
-Got my clicker.
-Tariq, Roots,
you got your clickers?
-Yes, we do.
-All right, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show,
and then you can all
like it and "wetweet" it.
-No, nice.
[ Audience groans ]
Nice.
-It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
Here we go.
This first one is --
the first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Drinking hair?
-Well, I guess I can already
tell where this is gonna go.
That guy is --
he made his decision fast,
the guy in the front.
I think this one --
this one's kind of a --
I think I already know
the answer to this.
-He doesn't want it to be
like his bracket.
-Yeah. All right,
the votes are in.
Let's see the results of this.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah.
That's true.
Yeah, I knew that.
Does that say 69?
Is that 100?
[ Laughter ]
Was that 160 --
-What is it --
-What numbers are those numbers?
-89.
-89, there you go.
That's when I was born.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
Oh, my God.
Don't cry, don't --
-I loved growing up in the '90s.
It was so cool.
-So cool, man.
-It was totally rad.
-You and the French Prince.
-This next one, here we go.
This one's good.
Says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Wow.
-I mean, I don't even --
I'm not even
gonna vote for that one.
I can just tell.
I just want to be on --
I just want to be friends
with the audience.
♪♪
I can already --
This is gonna be a landslide.
I'm saying this is in the
thumbs-down, in like, over 200.
-Over 200 thumbs down.
-Let's take a look.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-1-4-2.
-They did not like --
They did not like
that one at all.
But if you are too tall,
you cannot be --
-No, it's impossible.
-It's against the rules.
-Yeah, that's true.
Next one, here we go.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"Hello?"
"You knew it was me, right?"
"I did, right."
That one's not bad.
Yeah, the audience is kind of
divided on this one.
-You think?
-I think it's divided.
Think this is gonna be tight.
-I think this is a winner.
-You think it's a winner?
I think it's a tight race.
I think this is almost
a 50/50 tight jam.
-I'm gonna say 60/40.
-All right.
You're saying 63?
-Yeah.
-All right.
Let's check --
Let's see the results.
What?!
-Whoa!
There we go, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah!
-What?!
-WeTweet.
Whoo!
-That one made sense.
♪ Too hot to trot now, baby ♪
♪ Too hot to stop ♪
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-Dang!
That was -- wow, that was a lot.
That was the most anyone's
every voted on --
We've only done this --
[ Laughter ]
We've only done this once,
but anyways.
All right, here we go.
-But still, that's the most.
-Here we go.
Next up, right here.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I like that one.
All right.
-More informal.
-All right.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
Not as much
as the other one, though.
-No.
That's true.
All right, here's the las--
the final one.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
And, also, I want to say,
there's a couple people
out there that are pointing
the clicker at me.
You don't need to do that.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a remote control.
-It can't mute you.
-It can't do anything.
Aiming it at me, like,
trying to change my reaction.
-Ray to stun.
-I'm not connected to it at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
Click!
-Here we go. The last one,
the final one is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This one's gonna be 100%.
-There we go.
I think everyone's done.
People are just in a daze.
That one guy keeps pointing
the clicker at me.
-Yeah.
-Just -- yeah, you in the white.
What do you mean
it's not working?
-I don't know.
-It doesn't make a noise
or anything.
-It doesn't make a noise.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, ask the person
next to you.
Everyone's having
the same experience.
[ Laughter ]
He keeps pointing it at me.
-Wait, he should hold it --
hold it up.
Now click it.
"Bloop!"
There you go.
-Now it worked now.
It's all right.
Never mind, I got it to work.
[ Drumroll ]
All right, let's see the results
for the Scooby-Doo one.
-Yeah!
-Oh!
-Ruh-roh!
Oh!
Ohhhh!
That is tweet number five,
right there!
Scooby-Doo is the winner tweet,
right there, congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ They call me Mr. Bombastic ♪
All right, everybody,
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
Thank you for helping out.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it a
"wetweet," and enjoy.